pour certains d'entre vous, il semblait probablement que
ce jour n'arriverait jamais,
peut-être vous demandez-vous même si vous êtes
prêt pour cela
[Musique]
pour la suite,
vous n'avez aucune idée de ce dont je suis capable,
je ne savais pas de qui il  c'est que
je ne combats pas la France parce que je gagnerais, je
ne m'excuserais jamais d'avoir sauvé des vies, il n'y a
qu'une seule façon pour ce gamin de retourner
là-bas et c'est avec une laisse très courte,
je suis juste heureux d'aider les gens
[Applaudissements] ils
essaieront de nous tuer à chaque fois  jour,
peut-être que si vous vous entraînez plus et vous plaignez
moins, nous pourrions recommencer à sauver des vies,
faites-leur payer pour ce qu'il a fait à votre
monde, bienvenue au fils de celui qui a tué mon
mari. Je suis un super-héros humain normal.
J'aimerais qu'il soit mort aussi, mais pas pour  pour ton
bien, tue vite et pose des questions plus tard
oh ouais
Feltramide contre la viltromite ça n'est
pas arrivé depuis la Grande Purge
[Musique]
tu aurais dû mourir à la naissance
étrangère